within minutes of russia's invasion of
ukraine a strange thing happened in the
west suddenly we had millions tens of
millions of ukraine russia experts just
out of the blue people who probably
couldn't have pointed to kiev on a map
the week prior all of a sudden knew
everything about putin's motivations and
zelensky's motivations and the history
of ukraine and russia amazing how they
acquired that expertise
so quickly to help us separate facts
from fiction
we actually do have an expert here that
is pavel stroylov pavel stroylov is a
dissident a russian dissident who is
living in london he's done a lot of
history work on russia he actually has
top secret kremlin documents that he
stole and took out of russia uh from the
collapse of the soviet union and
afterwards hence why he is living now
under asylum in the united kingdom
i think that he will probably be able to
shed a little bit more light on the
situation in ukraine than the random
twitter blue check marks pavel thank you
so much for coming on
uh hello michael good uh thank you for
having me so my first question very open
very simple
what is going on in ukraine what were
the motivations for this invasion how do
we separate propaganda both western and
russian from the reality
well
it goes some way back as as you can
imagine you know the
truth is that people like putin
belong to the bloodiest
element of the soviet regime the kgb
secret police and uh after the so-called
victory in the cold war kgb
was never dismantled and they were
preparing to come back and that started
fairly soon after uh
1991 then
they supported president yeltsin in a
political crisis in 1993 where they
helped him in a forcible dissolution of
of russian parliament and immediately
after that they embarked on a quest
to start restoring the soviet empire to
return all the countries they've lost
they started with chechnya
it uh they failed like they're failing
now in having a quick victorious
military operation so they resorted to
genocide which was going on for some ten
years well once that was finished in the
meantime they openly
came back to power in in
in
as putin you know openly kgb president
well soon afterwards you had an invasion
of georgia in 2008
and ukraine next so from from his point
of view it is this simple objective
of uh reversing the the result of the
cold war and beginning by
uh restoring the the soviet empire in
its uh former borders i want to go on i
i want to go back to a phrase you just
used there you you mentioned the
supposed western victory in the cold war
the alleged western victory in the cold
war is what we're seeing in ukraine is
this
is this truly a return to the cold war
that dominated the last half of the 20th
century
well it may be
it is it may be something worse than
that really now where it has gone well
look now it is pretty obvious that the
soviet uh communist regime
faked its own death
it's not dead and you use
last week you saw putin addressing his
troops as comrades
you know ukraine doesn't exist it's an
administrative unit
in the ussr created by lenin let's take
it back well he he's
open you know it is his well he thought
it would be his triumph so he's starting
it and he is
prepared he wants a cold war for sure
but he's prepared for a real world war
as well
now what is your take on putin's
professed christianity because one of
the arguments we've seen in the west is
particularly among conservatives is that
the west has gone totally decadent we're
secular we're kicking religion out of
the public square we're suppressing
christianity and putin unlike his
communist forebears is actually publicly
supporting the church not only not
suppressing it but he's building
cathedrals he's supporting the church it
what what do you make of the image of
vladimir putin as the great christian
crusader
yeah well it is it's one of those little
kgb
games uh you know he he is pretending to
be a great christian prince because he
appreciates there are people in the
world
to whom that might appeal
uh um it certainly is not uh sincere as
as
the whole world has seen he certainly
doesn't believe in the shalt not kill
whatever else he uh he
believes and when it comes to crucial
moments well his rhetoric is soviet
it is not christian but the kgb has
believed for a long time really that
that
religion is a useful thing
to manipulate people and he's trying to
do that with christianity he's trying to
do the same with islam and his uh his
mufti of chechnya has declared at jihad
against ukraine a few
days ago and he is a puppet dictator of
cheshire is sending chechen troops there
as well
so putin's view is well he is
he likes religion
as long as it is his loyal church which
is helping his empire
building
like christ as a servant to caesar
wow that's a that's a great way to put
it
now
what what do we do now i mean you i i
suspect for a lot of listeners
this this may be the first time that
they've ever heard of some of these
geopolitical nuances uh if not the first
time i i suspect a lot of us just
haven't paid attention to it the
relationship of chechnya to moscow the
the idea that putin right now is using
these chechen groups who he previously
wouldn't have had a great relationship
with to go in to assassinate zelinski in
ukraine which he is saying is not even a
real independent nation it's an
administrative group and it it just
seems so
convoluted and yet and yet a lot of
people fear we're on the verge of world
war three because of this
particular eastern
geo-political crisis what are we
supposed to do now
yes well maybe
maybe we have already
lost
the world war three without without
firing a shot
look since since uh
1991 or thereabout and the west relaxed
a great deal and well we thought we live
in this comfortable world now with only
one superpower which is a christian and
democratic superpower is going to work
as a global policeman there are no
longer any big threats and then only
recently
you know you've
had
china taking hong kong and the best does
nothing dishonors all the all the
previous promises taliban takes
afghanistan the west does nothing and
now putin takes ukraine and and suddenly
you discover that we are surrounded
by uh powerful dictators and empires
anti-democratic
anti-christians determined to dominate
the world and the west is unwilling to
resist
and
well and basically the best
should better
find some bill
to resist that sooner rather than later
otherwise it's a question of guessing
which of them
is going to take over first whether it's
going to be chinese communists or putin
or
some form of taliban or something
similar
i suspect a great deal of the the
reticence in the west and in the united
states specifically to impose global
empire these days
to spread our values around the world as
we have said in the past is we don't
know exactly what those values are so
for instance when we look around the
world and think of china gobbling up
taiwan russia gobbling up
ukraine and other parts of eastern
europe we don't like that we don't like
the idea of the taliban taking
afghanistan but then on the flip side if
spreading western values in western
empire means nothing more than raising a
gay pride flag in kandahar well i think
a lot of conservatives say count me out
i don't even know what those what those
values are you've got the ruling class
in the united states protesting the
american flag
and hoisting the other other sorts of
ideological flags so what exactly would
it even mean to have a western empire
at some risk of of misquoting as i
i'm just
trying to remember i think churchill
said shortly before the second world war
that the main threat to western
democracy comes from within
and i think we are in the same situation
exactly well the reason why
the west has suddenly
lost well kind of seamlessly lost this
victorious uh
dominant position in the world is well
there are many reasons obviously you cut
your military uh capabilities uh you've
been unwise in really spending your
economy on a lot of uh stupid things uh
but the main factor in my mind is you've
lost the moral high ground well we no
longer believe in freedom of speech here
well we believe in counseling whoever is
a
dissident and that makes us
a less
efficient version of putin well we would
be assassinating and imprisoning them we
just you know we are just not decisive
enough or efficient enough
and you know and likewise well we
modeled our response to covet crisis on
china and maybe did it not as well as
our
great idols the chinese communists but
that is people they are modern it on so
absolutely well in order even to be able
to resist
the west must make an effort to be
different to become
the christian civilization which won
the the second world war to become the
free world which won the cold war
that is a really damning observation
that in the united states previously we
had a great deal of tolerance for
different points of view and we behaved
in a relatively much more civilized way
when it came to political disagreements
and now
if you say anything that in any way
contradicts the
liberal orthodoxy du jour and by the way
that orthodoxy changes day by day
sometimes by the hour you could lose
your job you could be kicked out of
school you could be de-platformed from
social media you could be kicked out of
your bank you could be put on a no-fly
list with no legal course of action to
fix it
what you're saying is
maybe vladimir putin kills his critics
well in the west they're just not
decisive enough they'll ruin your life
and your reputation they just they just
won't go to the logical conclusion of it
that that that we're seeing a soft
tyranny here so then how do you offer
what you might call a choice not an echo
that's what the conservative activist
phyllis schlafly in the 20th century
said conservatives need to offer a
choice not just a softer liberalism so
so what
in the west where you've got plummeting
rates of religion plummeting birth rate
plummeting marriage rates
mass abortion mass migration by the way
of uh you know
basically no effective borders
whatsoever certainly in the united
states with all of those problems how do
you get back to what you and what
winston churchill would have called
christian civilization
well that's yeah i i'm not sure i can
really give you a road map in a in a few
minutes uh uh look uh really the reason
perhaps really
you once again have to go to look back
into history and try to realize why this
happened and the reason really well
ultimately is the same as why
russia having overthrown
the communist regime in a
in a popular evolved well then suddenly
has a kgb president imposing a new
soviet uh dictatorship but a similar
thing has happened in the west because
the the cold war and the
the whole tragedy of communist
crimes well it happened with uh with a
degree of uh collaboration and
appeasement uh from the western elite
and there should have been you know
which we should have taken as a world we
should have taken a hard look at what
all of us have done uh you know rather
than let
effectively communists or you know
the western communists
change their colors slightly
like putin did abundant marxism that's
uh that's now a discredited idea and
invent some version which is slightly
plausible uh you know more or less for
some people uh in in the 21st century
you know you and
so there should have been but what you
should have had in really in 1991 was a
neural direct trial
of the of the communist regime and that
would have condemned in moral sense all
the collaborations
and and that would mean
a change of elite to something
more decent hopefully worldwide
but that didn't that didn't happen no
one wanted that for for obvious reasons
uh uh really at the top because because
you know it's it is risky you don't know
you don't want to destabilize when it
seems you've already
won the
the conflict but now we are facing a
similar situation basically you have to
resist
uh putin
now and well and and his likes you know
you have to resist putin you have to
resist china and that means that the
west will have to pluck up its courage
and take a lot more risks you know it's
a situation very similar to the
beginning of every world war or the cold
war well you you will have to fight
against the odds and if god willing you
win well then
learn from history
you know try to get to the bottom of
what happened and and you know hold a
proper uh
trial of the criminals and the proper
moral
reckoning
with everyone's responsibility for for
what has happened we'll get to more on
that one second first though i've got to
tell you about what gives me bliss okay
if you're looking for something in the
morning to increase your energy and
focus that does not have a ton of
caffeine i have got something for you
cacao bliss cacao bliss is a cacao based
super food powder to give you more
energy
and focus it's only got seven milligrams
of caffeine one gram of sugar not to
mention gluten free dairy free soy free
100 usda certified organic vegan keto
friendly it's every it checks every
single bite it will improve your mood
support your metabolism and crush your
cravings all you have to do is mix it in
with some hot water and maybe if you'd
like you can put a little almond milk or
something like that in there too look
how easy it is i've got the scoop right
here i scoop it into the cup boom boom
boom boom then you take the nice water
put that in
then you got your little mixer this
thing's pretty nifty
now you gotta make sure it's fully
submerged you don't want splattering all
over you just put it in very simple
there we go very simple okay
delicious absolutely phenomenal gives
you a nice energy boost if you want to
try it right now you can get it at the
link in the description use my code
michael mich ael for 15 off your order
total again click the link below use
code michael at checkout for 15
off your order cheers that historical
point you're making on
when a sort of discredited political
group just changes its colors ever so
slightly it still holds the same
ideology but it just kind of changed the
words it occurs to me that really even
just in my own lifetime conservatives
have pretty much always been
conservatives that's that's what we call
ourselves or just kind of conservatives
the left has been
liberals
progressives
leftists
this is that is they keep they change
the the words i mean political
correctness itself is just a series of
political campaigns to change all of the
words and then the moment one word goes
sour well you change it again but it's
the same old poison and and what what
you have i think quite convincingly
pointed out both from your exposition of
documents from the fall of the soviet
union but even just in this conversation
here is
when the soviet union died or faked its
own death
it just changed some of the words and
then you get the kgb guy at the head of
russia again
don't be surprised when he starts
calling his soldiers comrade
yeah yes exactly well that was you know
in on the russian side uh they were
really coming back to the question of
christianity and i remember these
conversations of kind of you know
semi-official people in russia in the in
the 90s and
early putin yes where they would be
saying quite openly well like okay well
our problem is you know to restore great
russia we need an ideology and we've
lost
marxism yeah what can we jump on and you
know and that's you know and that is the
origin of all their games with
christianity and and even islam but the
similar problem again you have here
marxism was discredited well you did not
have this world of uh dominated by lots
of industrial workers and you know
a small group of capitalists fighting
against each other economy did not
develop this way and so the event and
again if you if you i
don't know if you learn your lgbt
history uh in uh during the lgbt history
it's mandatory
yeah well it is and i think what what
they teach you and it is true is that
the whole at least in britain the whole
things started
from a campaign of
of uh uh
lgbt uh gays and lesbians in support of
minor strike and i've seen the the
documents in the
archives of the communist party of great
britain about organizing that that
campaign that is really that is their
genesis they were looking for some you
know some flag
to rally their supporters around once
the red flag was discredited it was it
was you know you can't you can't trace
this
you know
i'd like you to speak a little bit more
about that because i think a lot of
conservatives
looking around they they notice that
american leftists have a great a greater
degree of loyalty to the lgbt rainbow
flag even if they're not gay or sexually
sort of eccentric in any way they have a
greater degree of loyalty to that
rainbow flag than they do to the
american flag and you think well what is
this real something tells me this is
about something more than just
sexual attractions can you tell me a
little bit more about that history
yes well
not not very much i did not really
specifically study the details of this i
just you know looked through the
archives of the communist party and
discovered some of the documents to what
at that point really just seemed to me
ridiculous you know
sort of gays and lesbians and support of
of a minor strike
you you sort of you sort of imagine
completely different types of people as
gays and lesbians and and uh uh
strike and pearly miners yeah yeah but
then you know as you saw this whole lgbt
wave you know becoming more and more of
the official western ideology and
oppressive and totalitarian communist
style you know i it came back to me but
you know maybe you still need
a more thorough research of that too but
so so this raises
a a kind of interesting
inversion or a mirror between the west
and russia because russia had its
ideology ideology a word popularized by
the communists they had their communist
ideology for a century or a little less
than a century uh didn't didn't work out
it was totally discredited and so then
they looked for some kind of animating
ideology and seemed to have found
christianity to be at least somewhat
amenable to to that they could pretend
to be christian and maybe that would
give them a sort of animating idea even
if in practice it were a little more
complicated in the west
we used to be christian and now we seem
to have an animating ideology of uh
inclusion equity diversity lgbt you know
all of the
all of the pop slogan words so if that
is our animating ideology is that enough
to win a world war
no well certainly it isn't as i said you
you
you lose you immediately lose if you
kind of if you make the
human rights
all about lgbt and abortion then
obviously well you you just let your
enemies like putin
say well
we don't need human rights you know and
to say well proper
decent christian nations don't need
human rights and in a way he's flirting
with christianity
and obvious as he prefers to put
conservative christian values he put it
more politically it has been simply
exploiting your weaknesses you know look
stallion would have been silly and not
to condemn holocaust it doesn't mean
that he loved jews right he was
exploiting weakness of his of his enemy
and likewise hitler was condemning gulag
not because he was such a humanist but
because he was exploiting the weakness
of his enemy and you'd better get rid of
these weaknesses now of course well
obviously we are all in favor of
treating people fairly and not inquiring
uh
uh
into their uh
sexual
lives
too much you know that's all but i mean
we are all in favor of decency but
people had this for uh for a long time
but you know making this an ideology
well of course it is it is a weakness
right a weakness that's being exploited
uh this is a really
powerful warning pavel i i really
appreciate your coming on and giving
some perspective here uh to all of the
uh
ukraine experts who cropped up over the
past few weeks uh pavel where can people
find you if they want to follow you on
social media or or find any more of your
work
well you you should follow the
organization called christian concern
christian legal center in in the united
kingdom uh where we are
well essentially we are trying to
resist uh this uh uh this uh the
totalitarian aspects of this new
ideology
predominantly by fighting legal cases of
people who would be
who would be losing their jobs for uh
for
expressing some dissenting views or or
for even getting in some other legal
trouble right christian concerned
christian legal center
it's a wonderful organization i i really
uh really do uh
think they they're doing great work so
go check them out it's fighting that
two-pronged battle you've got the actual
geopolitical enemies long-standing
enemies of the west trying to encroach
now on our power and then as you point
out channeling winston churchill the the
battle you've got to win first is the
the internal one that's where that's
where the real threats are and and then
the west has to regain its strength if
it wants to project it around the world
wonderful stuff pavel stroiloff thank
you so much for coming on thank you
[Music]
[Music]